Josh Duggar has been found guilty on two
charges of child pornography today it's
my honor and privilege to join in this
announcement of a guilty verdict in the
case of the United States versus Josh
Duggar on Thursday the jury of an
Arkansas court founded the former
reality star guilty on both counts which
include receiving and possessing child
pornography this case represents a
significant milestone for the Western
District of Arkansas and our continued
efforts to combat child abuse sentencing
will happen in about four months Duggar
faces up to 20 years in prison and finds
up to two hundred and fifty thousand
dollars per count according to court
documents the 33 year old downloaded
files which contained images of sexual
abuse of children under the age of 12
while using his work computer at a used
car dealership during the federal case
which began on November 30th the defense
argued that the images could have been
accessed remotely or added to Duggar's
device by another party prosecutors
presented evidence to counter arguing
that Duggar deliberately installed a
hidden system on his work computer which
over the course of three days allowed
him to view the child pornography
Duggar's wife Anna whom he shares seven
kids with along with other members of
the family sat front row during the
trial God's grace can give me the
strength to love Josh when others would
say he doesn't deserve it back in April
shortly after Duggar was arrested Duggar
sister Jill Dillard and her husband
Derek spoke exclusively with E.T calling
the situation quote very sad on
Wednesday Derek took to social media
ahead of the guilty verdict and wrote
praying for justice this morning
Duggar's cousin Amy Duggar King also
tweeted Justice for the children Duggar
previously starred in TLC's 19 Kids and
Counting which hasn't aired since 2015
after the network pulled the reality TV
series over accusations that Josh had
molested four of his sisters and a
babysitter in 2015 Duggar publicly
apologized for his pornography addiction
and cheating on his wife at the time
Duggar's parents Jim Bob and Michelle
sat down with Megan Kelly on her former
Fox News show The Kelly File where they
opened up about how difficult this was
for their family we were shocked I mean
we were just devastated I don't think
any parent is prepared for trauma like
that we tried to make things as normal
as we can but also you know Michelle and
I both were keeping Alan Josh you know
all the time we I think as parents you
feel like a failure when one of your
kids does something wrong you feel like
if I had done more training or or maybe
something else that this wouldn't have
happened but the truth is that kids will
make their own choices and they will
make their own decisions even though
you've taught him what's right and wrong
foreign